Scholars are even skeptical of the idea
that there was even necessarily schools
of thought as such at least in the
earliest period but a messy exchange of
different ideas and perspectives on all
conceivable
topics eventually over the centuries
certain ideas of course became more
popular and widely accepted than others
and certain scriptures also were
increasingly seen as canonical or not
this is why by the time of the Council
of NAA a kind of Canon was already
present because certain texts such as
the four gospels in the new testament
which is simply the most popular out of
all these different scriptures that were
going around